ça fait changement alors bonjour je
m'appelle l'admr yvan merci d'être là
encore présent cette semaine à notre
espace autochtone en direct deux bonnes
nouvelles aujourd'hui nous célébrons le
deuxième anniversaire des espaces
autochtone dont je vous invite à aller
sur notre site voir tout ce qui a été
fait depuis deux ans et puis deuxième
bonne nouvelle nous allons vous inviter
à lire aujourd'hui parce que il ya deux
événements un qui a lieu en ce moment
c'est le salon du livre de montréal et
un autre qui aura lieu la semaine
prochaine c'est le salon du livre des
premières nations qui a lieu à québec
mais d'abord voyez ça c'est la fiche du
salon du livre des premières nations
la thématique marqué l'imaginaire donc
nous allons marquer l'imaginaire avec
notre invité aujourd'hui il s'appelle
louis car le picard si oui nous allons
le joindre à québec il est le directeur
de cet événement dont jean louis carles
voilà alors vous êtes là on va vous
entendre dans un instant parce qu'ils
avaient pas de sont pour l'instant mais
avant je vais présenter évidemment nos
chroniqueurs habituels donc tout juste à
côté de moi charlebois kooren bonjour
charles avec vos charmes on va parler
d'un spectacle qui aura lieu dans le
cadre du salon du livre des premières
nations
oui oui également et on faire découvrir
un artiste que je ne connaissais pas le
théâtre de marionnettes donc c'est le
plaisir et puis avec vous et lisse queen
d'abord bonjour heureux bienvenue vous
étiez absent pendant quelques semaines
donc merci d'être venu à votre post est
avec vous on parle de littérature mais
dans grand nord donne un nom et aussi
avec plusieurs recommandations à
optimisation des livres donc on prend un
papier un crayon puis on va pouvoir noté
et ça va être comme ça de toute façon
tout au long de l'émission parce que on
a plein de livres à vous faire découvrir
alors on s'en va tout de suite à québec
on retourne voir louis carles louis
carles c'est la septième édition de
votre salon du livre des premières
nations est souvent j'entends dire mais
je ne connais pas pourquoi on connaît
pas plus mais c'est une excellente
question nous c'est sûr que comme vous
le dites ça fait sept ans qu'on
travaille
damman offrir ce lieu lost un moment là
particulier qui soit dit en passant est
unique au canada
c'est un festival annuel grand public
comme ça uniquement dédié à la
littérature autochtone oui c'est unique
au pays alors de plus en plus j'en
vienne d'année en année et
c'est un secret bien gardé de moins en
moins bien gardé et on en est très
content
oui il faut pas que ça reste un secret
bien gardé il faut vraiment que les gens
le connaissent et s'y rendent et en fait
la nouveauté en cette 7e année c'est que
vous n'êtes plus seulement sur le
territoire de wendake et vous êtes à
québec pour cette édition la wii
véritablement c'est important pour nous
particulièrement dans un contexte vous
savez à peu près à ce moment si l'année
dernière
le ville de québec or reçu la nomination
de ville de littérature de lunesse cui
c'est une nomination ou demain hyper
importante pour la vie mais qui vient
reconnaître un peu les efforts qu'il ya
dans la région
le dynamisme finalement littéraire à
tous niveaux est l'une des le des
facteurs qui était tenu en compte par
l'unesco par les autres villes
c était la présence du festival du salon
du livre des premières nations des
éditions et narac de la librairie à
nérac donc de trois institutions
spécialisées en littérature autochtone
ce qui est assez unique encore une fois
au pays le pardon est ce que ce sont les
trois seules maisons d'édition au québec
qui font dans la libération au total il
y en a plus
mais ça dépend non mais écoutez ses
musiciens et narac c'est la seule maison
d'édition autochtones francophones
oui mais oui bien sûr que d'autres
maisons d'édition au québec sont pas toc
tonne me publie des auteurs autochtone
quand même ayant notre plus en plus haut
et un ça c'est intéressant entendu il ya
de plus en plus oui entretien mémoire
d'encrier le monde a crié évidemment une
énorme à 10 1 est un incontournable
mémoire d'encrier qui nous a quand même
fait découvrir la voix de joséphine
bacon rôle de natasha khan ap fontaine
de naomi fontaine et que publier ou si
d'autres auteurs
autochtone qui était déjà connue là
comme jean sioui domestique au chaud ou
moi même c'est vrai le week-end vous
n'êtes pas au salon du livre de montréal
actuellement pourquoi parce que vous
n'avez pas de nouvelles publications
plusieurs facteurs je voudrais mais le
principal facteur est temps que je dois
me concentrer évidemment sur les
non-dits les premières nations
j'ai pas encore trouvé le moyen de me
faire cloner je pense que mon conseil
d'administration ne veut pas on me
répond je vous dirais mais aussi non
j'ai pas de nouvelles publications
effectivement là cette année
il ya sûrement quelque chose quoi dans
les plans il ya quelques choses iraient
nouveau recueil de poésie l année
prochaine pour moi encore par contre ça
je voudrais en parler tout de suite en
fait c'était vous avez fait vous avez
écrit la préface d'un ouvrage qui
s'appelle nous sommes des histoires
réflexion sur la littérature autochtone
vous le connaissez bien maintenant le
livre ce qui vous en avez fait la
préface parlons-en tout de suite parce
que cet ouvrage là ce n'est pas un roman
c'est pas une bd c'est pas de la poésie
ça sent plutôt un essai et qui inclut
plusieurs auteurs et pas seulement ici
au québec et à travers le canada
oui c'est vraiment travers le canada et
même certains du côté américain de
mémoires
écoutez ce terrible c'est un
incontournable je sais pas quel point
c'est un livre qui peut je pense le
livre peut séduire quand même un grand
public mais je ne voudrais pas dire que
c'est pour le grand public parce que ce
sont plusieurs essais plusieurs
réflexions finalement critique théorique
ou de le partager témoignages
d'expériences de différentes personnes
de différents intellectuels et des
auteurs la grande majorité sont des
auteurs autochtone anglophone quelques
non autochtone aussi qu'ils présentent
leur vision de la littérature autochtone
et c'est extrêmement important
c'est un livre qui sera particulièrement
important dans les universités dans les
départements de l'être les facultés de
lettres au québec
parce qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens
allochtone et autochtone confondues qui
s'intéresse aux littératures autochtone
qui veulent étudier la littérature
autochtone du québec
oui mais qu'ils n'ont pas les outils
théoriques en français et ont souvent
ils doivent se retourner bien sûr les
outils théoriques la littérature
québécoise mais qui ne correspond pas à
notre réalité ou à ceux de la
littérature de la francophonie qu'on
n'est jamais sûr ce que ça veut dire non
plus ce sont des réflexions finalement
qui répondent qu'ils qui réflète le
milieu intellectuel anglophone
autochtone mais qui vont donner des bons
outils est ce que ce sera suffisant
j'espère qu'un jour on aura nos propres
réflexions d'auteur autochtone d'avoir
théorie critique et tout ça et on n'est
pas encore rendu là mais ce livre est un
incontournable pour toutes les facultés
de lettres les départements de
littérature au québec c'est un incongru
et dandrès canada francophone stone en
contournant alors ça s'appelle donc nous
sommes des histoires réflexion sur la
littérature autochtone sur facebook on a
demandé aux gens de réagir on leur a
posé des questions en fait on leur a dit
connaissez-vous la littérature
autochtone si vous aviez des
recommandations de lecture que
suggéreriez vous et on a eu des réponses
et là je vais vous en donner quelques
unes parce que c'est intéressant on va
voir ce que les gens connaissent de la
littérature orale tonnes il ya caroline
qui dit elle est franche à eddy n'ont
pas beaucoup et j'aimerais beaucoup
vraiment il a dit je viens de me
procurer d'ailleurs je lai elle vient de
se procurer à moon un petit livre de
nouvelles dans lequel vous avez écrit
une nouvelle justement ça c'est à moon
un excellent petit livre vous avez une
de vos nouvelles qui font partie
d'ailleurs de vos chroniques de kits
chic
ouais effectivement cette nouvelle note
de verdun d'employés dans le premier
tome des chroniques de kitsch et puis
bon c'est une décision du tas rial avec
la directrice l'acquis aussi dit non
cela bon le ton qu'il t'est pas tout à
fait semblable aux autres ça venait des
balances et certaines choses ouais alors
bon la veille
et comme celle gens m'avaient contacté
pour participer au livre on se dit waouh
oui j'ai quelque chose de déjà tout
écrit
on va leur travail est un petit peu pour
qu'elle soit vraiment indépendant oui
mais c'est vraiment le même univers
alors les gens qui ont apprécié
cette nouvelle là où il passe adresses
électroniques des saucisses et c'était
très bon très bon un peu noir par contre
mais bon je vous raconterai pas le punch
de votre nouvelle mais oui et puis on
aille en appeler d'autres et là j'ai
découvert que mélissa mollen dupuis
avait participé à ce petit recueil de
nouvelles
alors ça c'est une suggestion de
caroline qui a beaucoup aimé le livre
mais aussi une excellente plus comme les
deux jeudis à 10 mois ce que je voudrais
faire d'avis et de l'armée a dit on est
pris de faire de la sensibilisation pour
se battre pour l'environnement et
finalement il nous reste plus autant
qu'on voudrait pour écrire mal tellement
une belle plume
oui faut juste la tâche et pour qu'elle
puisse écrire c'est vrai pour moi
c'était vraiment une super belle
découverte
alors autres suggestions de nos
internautes kiriaki dit à l'ats elle
donne deux auteurs dont un qui n'est pas
autochtone mais qui écrit sur les
autochtones
il s'appelle daniel corones oui corones
peut-être c'est au héros et ne s ça
s'appelle j'ai perdu la foi je sais pas
si vous le connaissez
et sinon elle parle elle par dennis p
kiwan je reviens de marcel petit coup et
ça vous dit quelque chose
si je me trompe pas c'est un recueil sur
son site un témoignage de vie 1 2
mersen petit coup de petits coups et oui
mais les attikameks malheureusement très
peu écrit jusqu'à maintenant je dors
très peu publiée très peu écrit ouais et
c'est une contribution de monsieur petit
coup et qui est intéressante pour
comprendre le parcours d'un homme
autochtone qui est qui pas toujours
évident mais c'est pas ça peut être
intéressant pour un certain public
effectivement oui oui j'en parlais cette
semaine avec joséphine bacon parce que
j'ai fait une entrevue avec elle et elle
me racontait que justement il ya pas
beaucoup d'hommes autochtone qui
écrivent en fait ce qu'ils écrivent ou
les écrive une poésie mais à travers
leurs chansons par exemple on ans dans
le théâtre
mais c'est sûr que pour ce qui est de la
poésie et des romans ce sont plutôt des
femmes qui écrivent une usine ou
définitivement ya beaucoup plus de
femmes innu que domino qui ont publié
ces pôles côté des autres nations alors
je pourrais pas dire que c'est
nécessairement le corps d'accord
d'ailleurs je parlais des wendat les
gens vont parler de moi les gens vont
parler de jean sioui jazz si oui oui de
léonard qui était la première femme à
avoir publié un recueil autochtone en
français au canada
mais sinon c'est beaucoup d hommes donc
ça chaque nation absolument
alors là je vous en donne deux autres
qui nous ont été lancés comme ça
intéressant eve nous dit chronique de
kenshi qui de lui car c'est donc ce
serait mieux
et puis une autre myriam qui dit les
livres de times king il est valable à
thomas sky mais elle a dit
particulièrement l'indien malcommode
c'est vrai qu'il faut lire la dia
malcommode c'est vraiment beau est ce
que vous faites violette
oui des traductions intéressant oui six
ont fait maintenant au canada bond dans
le passé c'est souvent des traductions
faire en france et évidemment c'est des
fois semences adaptées pour le même un
peu un peu moins intéressant peu trop
pour les francophones du canada
mais les derniers de thomas sky notes et
radio canada
je pense à brève histoire des indiens du
canada qui est un livre extraordinaire
l'un des mal commode ouais oui ça paraît
on le voit la différence est vraiment
flagrante entre une traduction faite en
france est une traduction faite ici par
les gens d'ici la trêve
est ce parce que le langage n'est pas
pareil c'est normal
la date pour un public oui mais pour
avoir travaillé dans des écoles
autochtones ou pour des écoles
autochtones caviardant choisir certaines
traductions malheureusement il ya des
certaines oeuvres que qu'on peut pas
enseigner parce que nous public et
autochtone alors évidemment quand le
jeune qui est sur une réserve dans
l'histoire parle avec un slam parisien
alors ok pour l'instant je vais le dire
à nos auditeurs qui nous suivent là et
nos téléspectateurs qui nous suivent sur
facebook si vous avez d'autres
propositions faites le maintenant c'est
le temps de le faire je vais te dit tout
de suite vers hellich parce que
j'aimerais qu'on aille faire avant de
reparler du salon du livre des premières
nations
qu'on se rende dans le grand nord parce
que là bas on a fait des suggestions il
n'avait aucune du grand nord mais vous
vous avez aussi des suggestions à nous
proposer les tendances actuelles
oui et dans le nom canadienne ces
combats de littérature autochtone les
librairies les maisons décision et dit
que c'est toujours le sujet de penser
non autochtone qui le plus vendeur est
le plus populaire pour les livres pour
les adultes et aussi les livres pour
enfants
et puis un livre qui s'appelle finding a
refait ce qui sort du camp il ya une
traduction en français prévu c'est
encore sur le marché
mais c'est un ancien élève de
consignes autochtone à whitehorse qui
ramassait les photos et les vignettes de
la vie à whitehorse dans cette école
tasso fonctionne et et puis sa sortie en
2015 quand ça s'est sorti c'était prévu
juste pour les anciens élèves ou leurs
descendants
mais c'était tellement populaire wiiu
tellement de monde pour ce livre la
queue et les jambes partout au canada
les anciennes élèves leurs familles qui
dit nous aussi on était photo nous on
veut contribuer à ce livre là et puis
ils ont relancé ce livre là c'est sorti
en octobre le deuxième édition
d'accord et puis maintenant la doline
wever qui est la femme elle vient de la
première nation testing luth oud ou
quand elle maintenant elle veut que ce
livre l'oeuvre dans les écoles au canada
et puis que tout le monde soit au
courant de cette histoire est donc ce ne
sont pas que des photos il ya du texte
aussi aura conduit à ces les vignettes
de les élèves et elle veut vraiment que
chaque élève peut parler de leurs
propres expériences et puis l ai dit que
l tout mais ça et elle savait que
c'était important mais quand le livre
sorti il ya même les gens ont eu quand
même les gens à whitehorse qui dit on
est jamais sûr qu'ils ont pensé non
autochtone ici dans notre village et
puis elle dit que ça c'est vraiment
samantha quelle ampleur quand on manque
l'histoire dans deux territoires mis
alors à tout ce qui a été publié a été
vendu je pense qu'il va falloir sortir
une nouvelle édition
oui mais société en octobre et en sortir
une deuxième édition et puis les clichés
a maintenant acquis que ça c'est
maintenant dans les librairies et puis
maintenant il veut chercher un marché
plus plus grand quand on fait quelque
chose pour vous pour une petite pour un
petit tas de gens d'après ce groupe ça
prend de l'ampleur et tout le monde a
envie d'embarquer dans ce projet est
aussi agi comme c'était prévu juste pour
les élèves et leurs familles ont dit que
ça mais quand ça ce style tout le mans
s'intéresser et c 'est pas des fois on
pense de la lecture de tenter quelque
chose très précise mais s'intéresse tout
le monde quand c'est sur le marché oui
il ya oui puisqu'on parle de bien commun
oui
une histoire que tout le monde doit
connaître de toutes manières
les maintenant dans les livres
d'histoire il est important que la
littérature le reprennent aussi sale
week-end un livre comme celui là ce
qu'on pourrait le retrouver au salon du
livre des premières nations
verset de l'évangile parce que moi ce
que ce que j'entends c'est ça et souvent
les débats il ya plein de gens qui sont
intéressés pour le savez pas au départ
mais souvent c'est ça les gens ont eu
tous en tant qu'être humain des idées
préconçues tu sais c'est normal c'est
dans notre nature
ce qui est intéressant c'est que de plus
en plus les gens se rendent compte que
la littérature autochtone c'est pas une
chose que tu peux pas dire moi j'aime
pas le cinéma parce que tu vu une fois
un film que tu opprimés donc c'est un
peu la même chose il ya de plus en plus
de diversité dans la littérature
autochtone oui et cette diversité là on
essaie le au maximum bien représenté au
salon du livre des premières nations
donc bon évidemment je peux pas je peux
pas répondre si ce livre en particulier
se représente mais il ya effectivement
ce genre d'ouvragé que l'on retrouve
bien sûr d'accord alors là on était au
yukon allons hellich dans les
territoires du nord-ouest vous avez
parlé aussi à des libraires une glace de
leur côté à eux
est ce qu'il ya une littérature très
développé dans les terrines oui et
autour d'eux le même thème le pensionnat
autochtone mais quelque chose que le
week-end les dix qui est très
intéressant la baby est la femme qui est
le propriétaire de la librairie le 9
elle voulait aussi proposer un livre
c'est un écrivain autochtones de
colombie britannique
oui mais elle dit que les écrivains
autochtones encore ils ont les barrières
pour les sujets où les thèmes qui sont
pas les pensionnats autochtones et puis
elle a proposé une x d'apple tri et le
crédit est ce et c'est une histoire des
aînés de colombie britannique qui fait
un road trip hop housing a drainé dans
les grès de nouveau mais c est fait par
monique grèce 9 et puis elle se décline
maintenant avant elle écrit beaucoup de
livres sur la dispense une autochtone
les expériences dont un pensionnat lf
rituel mais elle dit que même avec les
succès de ses derniers livres comment
elle est proposée tous les les
résident aux maisons d'édition même les
gens dit on aime beaucoup d'histoires
mais l'équipe de vendredi on pense pas
qu'on peut vendre livre d'un écrivain
autochtone avec les personnages
autochtone qui ou ses sautes d'humeur de
la vie où l'absurdité de la vie et elle
a dit que c'était un gros défi pour eve
et d'autres écrivains autochtones de
être excepté pour d'autres sujets
oui c'est ce qui se met même en théâtre
saison ou dans les arts en général on
dirait qu'on est confiée à parler de nos
souffrances dans une dans une
publication dans une oeuvre dans quelque
chose sans pouvoir parler de l'histoire
de ma grand-mère qui va chasser le matin
un pic à l'obligeance fusil va la
marquer son organe on dirait qu'ils
comme moins d'engouement à ces histoires
l'hôtel l'histoire de deux amis l'être
mais à la façon autochtone fait on
dirait que c'est il faut que ça soit
plus travailler vraiment qu'on voit
vraiment l'image de l'indien dedans
encore mené jeudi l'indicé
donc j'ai un peu cette impression là
aussi c'est de voir l'inde pouvoir
l'indien souffrait pour qu'on agit est
ce que c'est ce que vous percevez le
week end au salon du livre les gens
s'intéressent à quel genre de
littérature autochtone bah écoutez je
pense que tout ça il vaut lui c'est vrai
qu'encore aujourd'hui parce que bon pour
faire plusieurs salons du livre atteint
en tant qu'auteur père en tant que
directeur de quoi donc je vous dirais
que souvent il ya quand même grand
public satan qui vont confondre
autochtone avec littérature historique
mais les gens qui viennent au salon du
livre des premières nations je vous
dirais il ya de toutes sortes de gens
beaucoup de gens de la grande région de
québec mais on est des gens qui
descendent de partout au québec et même
de l'ontario où là chaque année pour
venir à notre événement
c'est un événement spécialisés oui j'ai
déjà que descendre alors c'est sûr que
des gens plus habitué aux connaisseurs
qui lisent beaucoup de littérature
autochtone qui eux connaissent cette
diversité là pour le grand public dont
il ne connaît pas encore la littérature
autochtone j'ai encore certains
stéréotypes qui demeure oui par rapport
aux souffrances ou par rapport aux
légendes par rapport à la vie d'avant
l'arrivée des européens où les premiers
contacts
souvent je me fais dire bon qu'est ce
vous avez ça m'intéresse beaucoup moi je
veux qu est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que
vous intéresse que tout ce qui est
historique la baisse
donc si la littérature historique la
littérature des premières nations
parce que moi je vais vous proposer une
idée que renaisse de vengeance qui jeune
tueuse en série qui arrive à envier à
montréal et qui comme elle on pollue
mais bon c'est donc c'est très très
diversifié je ne crois plus
qu'aujourd'hui au québec
les auteurs soit encore obligé d'écrire
sur des thématiques qu'on les pousse
fortement dans ce sens là je ne crois
plus que ce soit l'alcool ce n'est pas
mon expérience oui
et enfin que les autres auteurs non je
pense que les gens se sentent au niveau
des dons des maisons d'édition je pense
que les gens sont assez libres d'écrire
sur ce qu'ils veulent des fois il ya des
commandes bien sûr mais ils en achètent
ou louent dans tous les domaines pour
juste pour les autochtones
c'est vrai ok là on part au nunavut
hellich parce que si une maison
d'édition autochtones au québec et on a
aussi une au nunavut parle en fait un
allié lappartient a désigné
oui et puis ça s'appelle la bête
milliards s'est défendu en 2006 et ce
qui est très intéressant avec eux c'est
que quand se défendent et s'engager de
publier les livres commerciaux les
livres que je pense peut être un succès
sur le marché
oui mais aussi les histoires des
communautés qui c'est important
peut-être pas juste un culte et en
particulier et il veut servir le marché
commercial mais aussi l'humilité dans le
territoire et puis c'est surtout on élit
pour les adultes mais c'est surtout les
livres pour les enfants qui fait parler
d'eux est un livre qui sort la semaine
prochaine qui s'appelle takana look et
c'est
l'écrivaine c'est un homme de igloolik
la communauté huglo l'ex1 veille pagnac
et c'est sur la ds inuits et aux siens
un peu les jambes coincées sednaoui et
puis chose avec ça aussi c'est s'était
illustré par une femme qui se termine en
acte à aurillac qui est également des
aigles au dic légende de kintélé golic
avec illustré par quelqu'un de la même
communauté
c'est magnifique en plus franchement de
la page couverture el had et tellement
belle donc on y raconte la légende de
sept nains mais est-ce qu'on ne reste
pas que dans la littérature jeunesse
dans cette maison d'édition quand même
si on n'y touche beaucoup
non et maintenant ils sont très connus
pour les illustrations dans les olives
sauce et ça ils ont aussi les choses
pour les adultes mais aussi une série
qui est sorti maintenant par la
chanteuse inuite ce jeune habitant
oui le mâconnais elle a proposé une
série pour les enfants et les médias et
s'est basé sur les conversations qu'elle
a eu avec sa mère sur comment le
territoire qui maintenant de nouveau été
transformée avec les arrivées des
européennes sauf
elle fait ça à travers les yeux d'un
enfant et puis le premier livre sorti en
octobre
ça s'appelle une haruna qui est qu'est
ce que c'est et c'est sur la première
fois qu'une petite fille a vu une
fourchette
et puis le nahd midi expliqué qu'avec
cette série c'est de voir ces comme on
parle des objets mais le symbolisme de
commencer à transformer l'accès oui mais
comme comme jeudi sous un blocage est
très connue au canada
et puis avec ce thriller ils ont des
gros atouts pour prospérer sans doute
pas il va être disponible donc partout à
travers le canada
oui ou non vous n'êtes est disponible
maintenant oui le livre dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure
kaka n'a lui que ça c'est la semaine
prochaine et puis aussi maintenant
ils sont en train d'essayer de faire une
partenaire yeux avec une maison
d'édition l'eau québec parce qu'il veut
que ça soit en france est aussi d'accord
louis carles le salon du livre des
premières nations dont il n'y a pas d'
inuit de au salon du livre présent je
dois avouer que jusqu'à maintenant non
ne jamais eu d'auteur inuit de deux
présents on a vraiment géant anglais
avec cette année mais bon ça manquait
jusqu'à maintenant évidemment nous comme
le titre l'indiqué on se concentre
particulièrement au niveau de la
littérature des premières nations mais
on est très ouverts onu et encore cette
année on aura l'auteur mitis catherine
envers m qui se représente alors on
n'est pas fermés aux autres peuples
autochtones
une question de programmation et
d'opportunités tout simplement d'accord
alors je vais continuer dans ce que les
les internautes ont suggéré comme
littérature autochtone je vais vous en
donner d'autres le legs des va et je
n'arrive jamais à dire son prénom au
bugue et chig rice un auteur anishnabe
de l'ontario est ce que vous le
connaissez le legs des vals we can oui
j'aime et je dois avouer que je n'ai pas
terminé mais oui une excellente
traduction d'ailleurs aux éditions david
qui était fait ces récents assez 2007
oui oui oui faucheux livre faut que je
le lise enfin il fait partie de ma liste
à lire bernice king ou l'histoire de
retourner ou ici bon c'est sûr il est
acquis que de la réserve pour aller
vivre en ville l'ensemble des
problématiques des dix ans charles
pourrait vous en parler ou alors ces
dilemmes qui nous a suggéré de l'ex
d'eva et alexandrine qui nous suggère
bernard assiniwi je pense a été le
premier d'ailleurs le premier écrivain
autochtone a publié en français au
québec bernard assiniwi que c'est l'un
des premiers où l'on peut dire c'est le
premier
on en est qu'à pêche s'est étalée même
année mais bon oui ceux où il bernard
est un incontournable
écoutez ce golog tous publiés au sens
que des livres des essais de l'histoire
fait votre vin vous même des livres
d'art 7d roma des légendes
je signe oui et elle touchait tout où le
maire s est un passionné plus bombée
cesse évidemment qu'on a rien mais
absolument absolument à elle elle a
suggéré bras coupés moi je suggérais la
saga db au tuc qui raconte l'histoire
des bo tube de terre-neuve là un peuple
qui n'existe plus cette nation a
complètement disparu très intéressant et
guy propose les étoiles s'éteignent à
l'aube de richard ouaga mise lui aussi
vraiment très bon lui je pense qu'il
vient de l'ontario un autochtone de
l'ontario et puis williams et la
williams il s'est trompé
will i am propose nearly tu de juliana
léveillé trudel alors c'est pas une
autochtone mais elle a vécu au nunavik
est la faute est vraiment un très bon
les québécois riz sur l'univers
autochtone mais c'est pas de la
littérature mais c'est pas de la
littérature au total mais si on veut
louer ou nunavik ça peut être une bonne
suggestion ça nous dit à peu près à quoi
on peut s'attendre lorsqu'on débarque au
nunavik c'est vraiment un livre très
intéressant mais ce n'est pas une
autochtone alors au salon du livre des
premières nations il va ya voir oui de
la littérature poésie des textes de
théâtre éléments non l'année dernière on
ne fait on essaie d'avancer cannes est
une thématique où une section thématique
dix ans il c'est sûr que bon la fiction
général
la poésie c'est toujours sa place à la
littérature jeunesse est toujours des
places qui sont faits parce que c'est
vraiment lock on trouve l'essentiel si
on veut de la production puis des
oeuvres mais chaque année on essaie de
faire une section thématique où on
aborde certaines oeuvres où certains
genres qu'on voit moins
l'année passée c'était par rapport à la
dramaturgie cette année c'est vraiment
par rapport à la bande dessinée octobre
on voit ça c'est vraiment génial alors
on espérait la voir sur notre plateau
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est diane
o'bomsawin qui fait de la bd
extraordinaire est ce que les gens
savent qu'elle est autochtone diane
o'bomsawin avec le nom mais l'impression
faudrait demander aux gens pour nous
c'est clair quand même son nom plumes au
baume pour nous c'est clair que c'est
aux ballerines mai
il faudrait demander à indienne
elle-même voir quelles réactions ont les
gens diane toujours créé en tant qu'être
humain je pense ça ne peut jamais renier
ses racines mais en même temps pour elle
ce qui était important je pense que
c'était c'était autre chose mais là une
oeuvre extraordinaire diane a vraiment
eu un rôle déterminant dans la bande
dessinée au québec particulièrement à
l'ensemble du mouvement de grogne
notamment aux années 80 c'est une femme
qui est qu ait connu dans le milieu dont
mais du grand public qui mérite vraiment
de se faire connaître davantage et ont
très très heureux de l'avoir avec nous
cette année
qui d'autre sera là d'ailleurs pour
montrer ce qui se fait en bd chez les
autochtones
ouais ben écoutez c'est sûr que la
majorité des 1 100 sont hors québec
parce que c'est un art qui n'a pas été
fait pour développer au québec beaucoup
on voit encore mais on je pense qu'on
développe la masse des vocations une
plus en plus d'auteurs que je connais
qui sont intéressés moi je vais vous
dire ce spécial là je suis un fan moi
même personnellement de bandes dessinées
de comic books autant disons franco
belges qu'américains
oui ça faisait des années que je voulais
faire spécial sept sections thématiques
la savait pas donné pour différentes
raisons
alors oui on était un album c'est win
bien sûr que qui sera présent tong hao
djodjic qui était un ami snabe de
kitigan zibi et qui lui est plutôt du
côté comics books donc il ya un graphic
novel justement son premier graphique
n'avons qu'à gadji et tout juste d'être
publié en français il vient d'être
traduit la version française est
toujours disponible cette année là cet
automne aux éditions en anorak donc en
même temps c'est un bon moment de
l'invité il donnera des ateliers entre
autres g lors du salon
comment écrire pour la bande dessinée
comme un cri pour la télé des ateliers
bref on s'entend un sonar pour donne une
des eaux aux autres et au grand public
aussi on à catherine oeuvre met qui est
très connu pour sa poésie à la gagner le
jeu
quelques années pour mon dieu belle
balade du nod de mon double il s'est
excusé moi nortel mars
je me rappelle bien anglais qui parle de
son quartier d'amin de winnipeg qui a
aussi publié depuis l'année dernière de
la bande dessinée donc gros gain
agricole ico donc le premier tome est
sorti et je crois que le deuxième est
sur le point de l'être
qu'est donc que twin axera des notes
évidemment on a des vies de robertson
qui sera avec nous qui a publié sa saga
cévennes generation qui est aussi
traduites en français qui est disponible
est un homme que je suis extrêmement
heureux d'avoir cette année c'est maicon
l'école maicon d'école qui est à ida qui
est basée à vancouver qui a inventé de
toutes pièces ce qu'il appelle aïda
manga donc c'est vraiment la rencontre
de l'univers disant asiatique du manga
et de la tradition de l'art autochtone
la côte ouest
parce qu'ils ont été formés par des
maîtres de la côte ouest et ensuite bas
il a pris aussi avec déjà en asie et il
fusionner ça donne des airs extrêmement
intéressante au niveau visuel qui sont
frappantes d'ailleurs amené jeudi oui
bon ça c'est son dernier qui périssent
données wars de blink alors évidemment
ce sont ya des cases de bande dessinée
mais on voit quand même
les envoyés des
le style est le peu de l'ouest excusez
ce qui est super intéressant peut-être
se montrer pour les spectateurs c'est
que l'ensemble de ces planches forment
en fait une oeuvre a donc c'est une
oeuvre visuelle convoi on peut même
détachée les pages du livre et en faire
une oeuvre sont l'école on peut l'aider
t il ses formes
une oeuvre complète alors ayez fait
payer quelques années red eagle eye de
manga qui étaient dans le même genre on
pouvait faire il nous invite est même
sûr sur youtube à briser votre livre
fait 11 9 on peut faire la même chose
avec quoi redoubler alors c'est la copie
de quoi y attend que je mens et c'est un
coach personnel pour le faire mais moi
je trouve pas vexer à huy magnifique mon
dieu il faut se rendre au salon du livre
on a quelques jours encore pour
planifier notre prochain week end et au
salon du livre
évidemment il ya des auteurs et les
écrivains et tout mais vous avez aussi
une part plus artistique des spectacles
qui sont présentés dont un don va nous
parler charles parce que charles cette
semaine vous allez nous présenter à
travers cette oeuvre l'art et metteur en
scène qui est très peu connue en fait
maintenant cinq comédiens enseignants de
théâtre cette semaine je vous fais
découvrir the slits si oui qui est un
artiste c'est un artiste
multidisciplinaire au lieu dit
aujourd'hui face on fait du théâtre
comédien la mise en scène
il est d'origine wendat québécoise il
est né à montréal est toujours vécu à
moriat jamais en communauté son
grand-père arrêts qu'il a quitté la
communauté venus s'installer ici à
montréal
donc on peut dire de lui que c'est pas
un qu'on peut dire de lui que c'est un
autochtone de ville et urbain et il a
étudié à l'uqam
en art dramatique c'est ça il était
enseignant pendant plusieurs années il a
démarré une compagnie il directeur
général de le théâtre bell et ben gluck
babe ruth exactement et il ya également
lancé le festival
ouf qui est un festival de marionnettes
et c'est ça l'intérêt c'est ce qui nous
amène d'ailleurs vers le spectacle qui
va être présenté la semaine prochaine le
mais le festival comme tel lui il existe
aussi il a une date bien précise
oui le festival bat se déroule du 3 11
mars 2018 le festival
il a eu lieu en des bombes une excuse my
lai il aura encore lieu l'année pour
l'année prochaine exactement toujours
environ au même d'argent environ même
date avec excusez moi avec et plus d'une
centaine d'artistes qui est acquis que
programmé qui sont qui sont là pour
pouvoir faire des spectacles et des
choses comme ça et le festival bains
c'est un festival de marionnettes pour
jeunes et adultes
produit par la compagnie dès le début
c'est un des plus grands festivals de la
région donc elle c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important et la
région c'est mon rayon par la région de
montréal
donc c'est quand même assez intéressant
moi je te connaissais pas vraiment je
trouve ça l'fun que ça soit aussi un
autochtone qui est parisien un festival
de cette ampleur là je pense qu'on peut
voir un peu aussi ses inspirations qui
de quoi qui s'inspire s'inspire beaucoup
6,2 du pop de 2,2 de données ou un peu
hollywoodienne
il ya fait un spectacle s'appelle
monsieur p
il ya fait monsieur patate et dans le
fond donc il ya fait une version pour
adultes
une version pour enfants donc il ya
vraiment une inspiration un peu farfelu
le présentement il fait un spectacle
scolaire de fin de tournée scolaire avec
un spectacle s'appelle xavi rays qui est
un pirate donc il ya vraiment des ddv
vraiment pas dans une dans une
connotation autochtone ya vraiment voulu
s'établir en tant qu'artiste en tant que
comédien en tant que metteur en rien je
pense parce qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
entendu parler moi je le découvrais
quand j'en ai entendu parler
dernièrement je vois je voyais qu'il y
avait un spectacle de lui aussi au salon
des premières nations qui s'appelle
bienvenue akichi qui et c'est ça ce qui
m'amène là je trouve se trouvait
vraiment intéressant de pouvoir parler
de lui parce qu'il était présent au
salon des premières nations et moi je
voulais savoir en tant que metteur en
scène qu'est ce qui a apporté d'intérêt
sans atteinte on était en fête à la ou
désir de vouloir monter ce spectacle
avec les chroniques des kits chikhi du
niqab
je souhaite à être fantastique ce poste
un homme seul être humain fantastique
est un homme extrêmement généreux et
aucune imagination débordante et en même
temps c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent je
pense que bien cerner le recueil de bien
cerner ce que je voulais faire avec le
recueil moi j'avais eu l'occasion de
travailler exhaust l'un ya quelques
années pour un spectacle qu'on avait
présentée à québec
je me souviens mais plus dur mais ça va
me revenir mais votre couette avec le
théâtre poisse puis le spider woman
tireurs de muret miguel puis je l'avais
rencontré puis j'avais adoré l'univers
de jocelyn parce que justement c'est un
homme qui catch ville puis une ébauche
une imagination débordante et qu'est-ce
qui mène au spectacle je pense que c'est
ça en même temps le respect de l'oeuvre
originale
j'ai vraiment respecter l'oeuvre
originale lieu dû faire des choix
évidemment si le metteur en scène alors
que fait des choix
oui et moi en tant qu auteur du livre
original
je pense que ce qui me plaît le plus
vraiment puisque quoi je suis vraiment
satisfait c'est que respecter le temps
de chaque nouvelle le spectacle j'aborde
de majorque est quatre à cinq nouvelles
le livre une dizaine de nouvelles il y
en a choisi quatre pour faire le
spectacle bienvenue un critiqué et c'est
son choix à lui bien sûr et chacune des
nouvelles options différentes dans le
livre et dans le spectacle le ton est
vraiment différent pour chaque nouvelle
aussi et ça c'était un tour de force
tant que moi parce que les descendants
livre c'était pas évident parfois on
pouvait passer de quelque chose d'assez
cru à quelque chose de très très humain
très fragile très sensible et il le rend
bien ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que justin je suis suisse et c'est le
seul artiste à manipuler la marionnette
autochtone moi j'ai toujours voulu
essayer de d'élaborer sur cette
technique de lavage trouve ça vraiment
intéressant parce que c'est le seul en
fait c'est le seul qui le papy il est
plus ou moins connus on n'entend plus ou
moins parler c'est ce que bon il y avait
probablement un choix personnel envers
lui de vouloir de vouloir s'accomplir en
tant qu'artiste avant de vouloir
s'exprimer sur sa culture est chaud ça
je trouve que c'est je pense que c'est
ces nouvelles pensées aussi des artistes
autochtones de vouloir de vouloir
devenir un artiste mais pas un artiste
autochtone pour faire de l'art
autochtone nécessairement mais faire
simplement dollars c'est faire un
théâtre qui qui qui s'adresse à tout le
monde c'est sûr et c'est normal
aussi comme n'importe qui le fait
briller exact les artistes sont des
artistes et pas un artiste français
chinois ou autre n'est un art les
acteurs beaucoup plus en plus de soucis
je me tiens on revient un peu à l'idée
de vouloir parler des blessures mais de
vouloir parler de nous aussi mais de
vouloir simplement je s'exprimer aussi
utiliser différents cela aussi qui est
parmi nos rêves aussi pour continuer sur
ce que tu dit charles très important et
ça c'est le cas de toutes les
littératures de toute façon vous savez
une littérature naissante buts autant au
québec où la littérature c'est de la
poésie puis la littérature du terroir
oui puis m emmener les gens aujourd'hui
tu peux lire des romans policiers
littérature québécoise peut lire la
science-fiction tu peux lire de tout en
fait puis c'est le même parcours souvent
que tous les peuples vont avoir on
commence par témoigner du passé pour pas
perdre aussi un camp parle de légende
2002 juste de récits de vie
oui et puis ensuite on parle de double
est surreprésentée de ce qu'on vit même
emmené onu goût de rêver le futur et
c'est ce qu'on fait une positivement ou
négativement d'ailleurs on est juste le
goût de s'exprimer en tant qu'être
humain qui a quand même en tant
qu'artiste points mais en tant
qu'artiste qui est aussi autochtone et
donc qui ont un parcours qui a des
références qui peuvent être un peu
différente que des valeurs peut-être
qu'ils peuvent ou pas est un peu
différente
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez réussi
à faire avec
bienvenue à kitsch qui cliquent jeunesse
rime public juger du résultat
moi je moi qu en tant qu'auteur je suis
extrêmement satisfait de ce spectacle là
du travail à josselin d'ailleurs de
l'ensemble des artistes impliqués dans
le spectacle je pense que c'est un
c'est pas quelque chose que je suis gêné
au contraire ce serait très fière car il
est présenté voilà alors le spectacle
est présenté le 23 novembre à 20 heures
à la maison de la littérature à québec
fois des devoirs il faut aussi se rendre
au salon du livre des premières nations
qui a lieu dont du 22 au 25 novembre je
me trompe pas dans les d'assez bons 22
au 25 novembre à québec
et puis entre temps aller au salon du
livre de montréal voire natasha khan ap
fontaine naomi fontaine daniel si oui
charles bender emilie monnaie donc il ya
beaucoup de monde qui sont ton salon du
livre de montréal allait découvrir la
littérature autochtone et puis faites
nous vos suggestions
parce que l'émission se termine mais
vous avez encore le temps de nous dire
quels sont vos auteurs autochtone
préféré ce que vous nous recommandé de
lire et voilà puis encore une fois je
vous remercie d'avoir été là cette
semaine louis cainne picard si oui merci
beaucoup
un très très bon salon la semaine
prochaine on a très hâte de vous
reparler
merci beaucoup de l'invitation plaisir
merci beaucoup merci hellich la semaine
prochaine on vous on ne vous retrouvera
pas la semaine prochaine mais dans deux
semaines merci de votre présence merci
charme c'est où
bonne semaine à tous les deux c'est une
bonne semaine à vous tous revenez nous
donc vendredi prochain 12h15 pour un
autre espace autochtone en direct salut
[Musique]
où